it's stupid i know i'm glad my mom is
not here oh god
i'm very happy to see you alive and well
after this why thank you when you you
say death defying stunt in this industry
usually there are kind of air quotes
around that because you might be
tethered to the plane you're coming out
of no no
this was just stupid we went for riding
this plane my friends didn't know the
front of the plane opened so i opened
the front and came up and then crawled
out on the front of the plane of course
then they have to buzz the mountain to
try and you know so yeah it's just men
behaving stupidly is basically what it
is this was not pre-planned you just
went for it oh no you don't plan
something like that well you should no
you can't plant it or else it would be
then somebody would stop you if you
planted it they look like they're
leaning they're trying to get as close
to the mountains as possible were they
trying to tell you well my friend was
sleeping so what happened was i want to
get out in the front of the plane so
when he looked through the windshield
he'd seen me outside and not realize
what was going on and that's what
happened and it worked pretty good do
you know how high up you were
maybe two or three hundred feet not
crazy it was a propeller plane the plane
was 71 years old so you had an old guy
in an old plane well what could go wrong
there huh wait the plane was 71 were you
in the plane the same age aren't you 71
yeah i'm 71. so the same age yeah so
that's good so i wanted something i grew
up with basically no no we just went for
i
look it doesn't make any sense
it's so stupid i i was just trying to
like have some fun with my friends and
of course they had the video they had to
video it on there with an iphone and you
know did you have any fear no i didn't
have any fear i'm not i'm not some brave
person but believe me it just seemed
like a fun thing to do and it got a
laugh and the plane it doesn't it's not
like a jet where you're going 500 miles
an hour i mean we're only running about
147 i think 147 miles an hour at the
time so there's a door in the plane and
you came out of the door and waited
right i came out the door and crawled up
on the front yeah yeah i mean it's so
yes it's stupid i know i'm glad my mom
is not here oh god i was gonna ask if
your family has seen this and then your
friends and if they are are mad at you
today for risk this risk
no no no
the only people mad are people i owe
money to yeah yeah yeah they're the only
ones hey hey no but it was fun it was
silly i i was stunned at the amount of
publicity it got it it seems to be
everywhere just you know we just shot it
and i showed it to a couple of people of
course one of them sent it to i guess
entertainment tonight and you guys and
and then it went everywhere we are now
calling this your tom cruise moment oh
yes yes yes me and tom yeah very similar
yeah that's it me and tom
mission impossible leno yeah that's me
yeah and it would be impossible exactly
that's what it would be can we see you
in the next mission impossible movie uh
yeah if you see me it'll be impossible
yeah yeah let's just put it that way but
if you want to be a contestant on uh you
bet your life go to betterlife.com and
have people come in be contestants i
love what i'm seeing in the background
by the way i just read this show has
been sold and i think if not a hundred
percent almost 100 percent of markets
already yeah just about 100 markets it's
and it's kind of fun because there's no
politics there's no
it's a comedy show but with no politics
so that makes it kind of interesting so
you can appeal to everybody have to take
sides and throw rocks at each other so
just have a good time i mean it's
basically if people come out and we ask
them questions and they win not a great
deal of money just a fun amount of money
a few thousand dollars you know we have
fun laughing with them and people
laughing at themselves so it's going
very well all the contests have been
very pleased you know and uh yeah it's a
lot of fun i'm really excited about it
well and such an iconic show i mean
groucho marx how does it feel for you to
be stepping into these shoes and then
reimagining it well good i mean the show
is not much different than what groucho
did other than it's in color you know
but it's not it's basically the most
basic form of human contact people
talking to one another and everybody
does email and all this can texting and
all this kind of stuff but to see people
actually interacting
like we are now is fairly rare in
television you don't see that anymore so
that's what i think makes it work
it's a warm show and i think people feel
good about about watching it